[Music]
more insight into the republican races
for governor and senate here in the
state of nevada our new eight news now
the hill emerson college poll looked at
candidates leading the pack and today
politics now host john langler looks at
issues that matter most to republican
voters
the primary is june 14th struggling
candidates need to make their move now
before it's too late with two front
runners in these two high-profile races
we wanted to see what issues could sway
republicans before they vote we have a
governor more interested in locking us
out of work pointing out what's wrong is
usually how politicians out of office
try to get into office right now it's
hard to miss gop candidates using that
tactic before the primary the question
is what do voters think is wrong what
matters to them now remember these are
republican primary voters spencer
kimball is with emerson college it
conducted a poll of a thousand likely
republican voters across nevada in the
governor's race we asked which candidate
is most trustworthy on crime no surprise
gop front-runner and sheriff joe
lombardo leads by a wide margin in the
senate race republican voters say former
state attorney general adam laxalt is
most trusted to handle immigration polls
show he and lombardo are leading their
races turns out republican voters don't
think much of the work we do 86 percent
don't trust the national media to
accurately cover elections 69 percent
distrust local media in their political
coverage still the election comes as the
nation battles record inflation
everything is costing more our poll
shows that is what weighs on voters more
than anything else
44 percent of republicans say the
economy is the most important issue
right now immigration is a distant
second at 20 percent followed by
education and just something else
amongst republicans the economy usually
ranks a little bit higher than let's say
health care and so these numbers are
generally in the trends of what we're
seeing one lingering trend in the gop is
the 2020 election it's still a topic of
frustration even with a new election on
the horizon 56 percent of republicans
that we polled say former president
trump spends the right amount of time
talking about that and unfounded claims
of voter fraud he's already endorsed
lombardo and laxalt in their races going
against the nevada gop they're going to
have to make the case that they're
stronger than either lombardo or laxalt
john langler live local now